thank you
[Music]
so uh Chris Brown's back in the news oh
yeah shoot he beat up another girl wow
whoa no but it does involve a girl oh
just not in the way you might think so
you know like uh some concerts they do a
thing where they bring a fan up to the
stage brought her up to
boxing
one lucky winner there's been a slap box
with me Chris Brown have you guys heard
him [__] up have you guys heard his
testimony of what happened on his side
no it's Rihanna yeah is it actually like
worth hearing it's worth hearing
actually yeah yeah okay all right like I
don't know who's telling the truth
obviously because like you know we're
we're on social media so we know that
like how different what the public gets
could be from real life yeah what did
Ruby do uh but he was talking about how
they're like driving back somewhere and
he goes first of all I [__] up like
that's like I just want to put that out
there I shouldn't have laid hands on her
ever whatever but he was saying like uh
when they're driving back I think she
was like being like belligerent about
something and then uh she took his phone
like threw it out into the middle of the
street and then like with his her heel
was like stomping on him like while he's
trying to drive his Lambo or whatever oh
like you're like oh [__] I can see where
it goes in from like just stop up and
then maybe a second one and then but it
ends there and then he's like oh [__]
what did I do I kind of like like that
I'm like summarizing obviously but it's
uh it was cool to hear him come out
um way later on and then they asked him
well why didn't you share this like
right when it happened he goes right
when it happened like I [__] up so he
that was his way of going I'm just gonna
accept it and take everything that's
coming the way
um I want to I don't want it to make it
like I gotta defend myself uh so I
[__] up I should never have done that
but if you want to know the real story
this is what happened when did that come
out recently oh dang oh yeah yeah but
what about the other time he [__] up a
girl same thing she was hitting them
with the heels throwing away his phone
he did that again he'd lose his phones
all the time did he oh [__] hey but in
that picture that Riri came out with her
like her after she got hit by him she
that didn't look like a stop that looked
like a stop
it looked like she fought in a UFC match
today yeah but girls bruised easily dog
if I [__] hit a dog
[__] Tangerine goes
like it's [__] Bruce so easy he's a
big mofo too I think like six two or six
three oh yeah he's a big boy yeah he's
tall Riri not is she big is she tall I
don't know what's her height right can
you pull that up
really looks small but she doesn't look
super small but she looked petite but
she don't look big she's probably like
five eight yeah she doesn't look big at
all yeah but she's still got girl skin
it bruises so easy but after doing that
to Rihanna I feel like Chris Brown is
like he's he's like fine he [__] us
yeah
but before that didn't he beat up a girl
too
regardless of where he went Rihanna went
yeah he had a [__] billionaire yeah
yeah that's true I guess when they're
comparing themselves to each other it's
a pretty clear yeah distinction yeah and
then I do want to support her more
because I'm like I do feel bad that she
got beat up by Chris Brown I'm a real
fan I'm really over Beyonce I said same
same here me too really I think she's
hotter too actually I think everything
about her well Beyonce is still fine I'm
not gonna take that away I'm just saying
but the music I think I think Beyonce is
fine but I think Rihanna's sexy hey I'm
not I'm not mad I don't know the
difference what did Chris Brown do
because let's talk about dude I'm more
of a Kelly Rowland kind of Oh Wow Wow
hey Kelly Rowland had some good songs
though on her own yeah dude yeah name
half of one
um I'm a Survivor I'm a Survivor like
I'm not gonna give up Chris Brown yeah
so what he did is you know like at
concerts they'll do these things where
they bring a fan on stage and they'll
put them in a chair and then they'll
like dance around them Magic Mike stuff
yeah I'm the fan I'm not gonna do this
I'm not the dancer
well we get the idea
so he has his girl on stage and uh
starts dancing on her and then she just
won't stop taking her phone out oh and
he like you stupid gen Z [__] yeah at
one point he like puts it away for her
he's like nah like just live in the
moment like he puts it away man yeah so
here just take a look at me like but my
friends won't understand that's funny as
[__] he threw it this is not a good
close out her phone look at that hip
movement yeah yeah keeps going on her
phone oh my God I need a [__] um
yeah No One's Gonna realize that this is
happening to me right now
back if the answer is doing it takes it
throws it
just launched her phone it's gone that's
pretty funny
is that why people are like
Rihanna did that to you and beat your
ass up how come you did to her that's
[__] funny put on her phone what's
with this phone throwing it was in the
moment when he brought up that was in
the moment he's been traumatized by
phone throwing so it just kind of came
out you know Primal you know when you
get mad you kind of do throw your phone
it's Primal even I like even like if I'm
getting like like serious for a real
lift sometimes I forget my phone costs a
lot of money and I [__] Chuck it I
hit the lift and afterwards I go oh my
God what did I do
came to my senses how could I you throw
your phone you don't throw someone
else's phone very true yeah but what if
somebody landed on somebody's shoulder
and it's fine yeah but
Chris Brown apologists if you're here
though this this is this is America
right telephone someone's gonna catch it
oh oh I gotta Sue Chris Brown ow oh yeah
that's true I need a hundred million
dollars
so what are people saying about this
cell phone throw I mean they're just
making fun of it mainly but he doesn't
care he's like all right it's just a
phone yeah he doesn't give a [__] also I
mean just be in the moment man that's
true I think that's more important is I
mean not that you should do that but it
does look really dumb to just be like on
stage when like a artist is performing
to you yeah it does seem like it must be
like [__] why did I pick her because
that's like a once in a lifetime moment
yeah how hard is it to go yo Nick record
me and then your your homies recording
you and you have a way better angle than
like I'm gonna go up there myself and
then you have look trust me that's Chris
Brown dude trust me but dude I don't
think it's that unreasonable that I want
to [__] pull your phone out while
Chris Brown is laughing I think it's
unreasonable guy no I don't I'm not a
big selfie I'm the guy at a concert
that's like Dude put your [__] phone
away okay you know what I mean if you're
if you're this guy at the concert I'm
like you're not gonna watch that [__]
later so put it away you're not gonna
yeah but if you are [__] getting
danced up on by Chris Breezy what if you
went what if you got that uh at a Bad
Bunny concert magnification I'm gonna do
that what would you do if that bunny
pulled you up to Stage dude I shake I
shake that thing up
I tossed that monkey around it's more
about herself and what she wants to show
off than what Chris Brown is giving her
doesn't that crazy yeah and I think if
like one time before that he's like nah
don't like just put it away and then she
does it again that's probably where he's
like kind of had it yeah he just
launched it she should have had a 360
cam so she could just hold it telescope
GoPro on her head like this yeah the
head bow
the one that looks like a g string she's
she's not prepared actually but dude I
don't think you should throw anyone's
phone like this at the same time though
like if you're like balling
you're at my show I can revoke your
ticket but she picked she paying money
right to a certain I don't want your
money you pick you picked her out the
crop yeah but like would you rather get
like the what like the maybe 200 bucks
that she paid for your ticket but like
at the same time it's like you got your
fan like and that's the show that's what
people are gonna remember this image of
like somebody who's just like yo check
this this moment out you know what I
mean yeah it's like no dude it's like
let me [__] dance on you so I can
look sexy for this part of the show that
I chose and you're beautiful and I'm
beautiful you know what I mean it's a
[__] thing it's a gimmick that every
[__] artist does own that much of a
distraction form I don't think it's a
distraction it's a disrespect it was
yeah is it a disrespectful hey look at
me no I don't even think it's crazy
disrespectful I think he's just that
kind of that kind of person to be like
in your face he's already so edgy right
dude the top comment was could have been
worse
that's a good comment [__] that's what
I'm saying it's like it's it's on brand
for him to be like yeah I don't give a
[__] right you know yeah yeah honestly
watching that video of him chucking her
phone I was like mad for her you liked
it I was I was mad I was like dude I'd
be [__] pissed so you Chuck my phone
dude I think if I was at a concert I was
at that concert and I saw the phone I
would crack up me too that's funny you
know I'd be entertaining the way that
makes sense for like his brand yeah that
is true it does make sense for it did
you see the thing with Bad Bunny through
a phone yeah she threw a phone what do
you think of that I thought that was
funny he's like walking with his Camp I
guess maybe to Stage or from stage some
other girl that's not part of his Camp
just gets like starts catching up with
him it starts going like this trying to
like film them yeah and then he grabs
her phone and throws it in the water
like they're like walking by a river in
the water yeah I thought that was I
thought that was more acceptable than
this yeah because he's like I deserve my
[__] privacy right yeah you can't be
a random my piece there's a video of
Kanye doing uh doing that recently or
this this Paparazzi was filming him and
then he takes her phone and throws it
that made me laugh oh
because she was like dude stop [__]
filming me like get out of here get a
job loser you know Paparazzi was smart
they would hire another Paparazzi go hey
dude he's probably gonna throw my camera
so we catch well they caught it on
camera it's [__] funny that is funny
yeah see he knows I think it was a while
ago but it was like a Harry Styles
concert he's wearing this like you know
kind of like jumper looking thing that's
orange kind of skin tight right he's
like up there somebody checks a water
bottle oh yeah nuts we covered that here
yeah yeah I need for real just like he
has to [__] take a piece he became a
he became an equal I'm thinking about it
I think the the classy and probably even
have uh gain more fandom way is take the
phone and now perform into the phone
also with her and then Chuck it people
do it give her a souvenir to take home
with that's what that's what and then
wipe all that
restore
on it took the phone recorded himself so
people were like yeah and then still
chose to break it afterwards
or he downloaded the update people were
also saying like everybody was also
saying oh damn you know her phone's
still unlocked
catch it yeah but no there's there's
also footage of a girl giving it to her
at the end of the concert like they met
her outside which is great that's cool
as that person to do that but what a
good Community huh you shouldn't throw a
Fan's phone interact your concert and
you're gonna give him a lap dance so
that's part of the [__] deal oh yeah
right if you tell me like if you were to
like uh we started this whole thing over
and we were like all right a artist
brought a fan on stage for that type of
gimmick and then ended up and told the
story and checked their phone which
artist was it
um if it was like oh Chris Brown oh yeah
I can see I would literally name all of
them I could see Ariana Grande doing
next year
it's meticulous
at creating their
performance they don't want
contamination like even like Katy Perry
right all her shit's [__] crazy
Spirals and candy canes and [__] she
didn't put all that effort into for
someone to come ruin her show like I
need to do a magic like computer totally
see Katy Perry like get this [__]
whack-ass black phone out there it needs
to be [__] neon pink or something
yeah I wonder how they handled it at
like Magic Mike live because I'm sure
lots of people want to do that and this
is the whole show like a lot of it I
think I think what you said is the best
way to do it perform to the camera then
delete all that yeah and then download
the update switch the language to
Spanish or something that's why you need
to someone needs to patent the freaking
sticky hand phone case so when someone
throws it just go forward
that's kind of [__] up that use a
pattern specifically for phones yeah but
do you think bringing up a fan on stage
it's like you're also kind of opening up
a door exactly oh yeah you never know
what it's gonna you have to know yeah
how do you know she's on she's not
underage oh she don't look underage
honestly she looked like she was 13 to
me dude she looked like she's like Terry
Hatcher you got the overage Heavies
like you think she look like a woman you
think this underage look like a fan of
like a rule cast members those are the
Pelosi's does she look does she look
like she's annoying yes do I think Chris
Brown should have thrown her phone no
wow I like that you have a lot of
merchants we should have slime dirt sure
yeah Nickelodeon
yeah yeah yeah he chucked her phone and
then slammed her that's okay after after
the left is
[Music]
foreign